القواتُ المسلحةُ الروسيةُ وريثةُ مجدِ الجيش الأحمر الذي دمر مشاريعَ الهيمنة النازيةِ في القرن الماضي.
الجيشُ الروسي بقوامِ أكثرَ من ثلاثةِ ملايين جندي بين الأساسيين والاحتياط وآلافٍ من الطائراتِ والدباباتِ والحواماتِ والصواريخِ البالستية والدفاعيةِ والسفنِ الحربية بأنواعٍ مختلفة
كلُ ذلك بُني على أساسِ عقيدة واحدة هي الدفاعُ عن وحدة أراضي روسيا واستقلالِها.
لكن كما يقال إن كلَّ ساعة ولها ملائكتُها.. أيضا لكل زمنِ خصومُه الجدد.. تتغيرُ المسمياتُ والحقيقةُ واحدة هي أن هناك دولاً تريد أن تبتلعَ دولاً أخرى
نتيجةً لضعفها وإن لم تكن ضعيفةً فتعمل على إضعافها وتمزيقِها للسيطرةِ عليها وما جرى في يوغوسلافيا ومن ثم في ليبيا من أفضلِ الأدلة على ذلك
أما الخيارُ الآخر فهو نشرُ قوات أجنبية، تماماً كما يحاولُ الناتو ومن خلفِه واشنطن فعلَه الآن على حدود روسيا.. وهو ما أثار حفيظة موسكو التي أعلنت أنها ستقفُ ضد هذه المشاريع.
الرئيس الروسي /فلاديمير بوتين/ قرر تحديدَ مجموعةٍ من الأهداف العسكرية أولها أنه لن يُسمح بالتفوق العسكري على روسيا من أي بلد كان وثانيها العملُ على الحفاظ على التفوق العسكري بما في ذلك القدراتُ النووية.
من جانبه أعلن وزير الدفاع الروسي /سيرغي شايغو/ أن خطة عملِ الوزارة لعام ألفين وخمسة عشر عُدلت وفقا لقرارات القيادة بشأن زيادة القدرة القتالية للقوات المسلحة على خلفية الظروف السياسية والعسكرية.
وقال إنه جرى تدقيقُ معايير تزويدِ القوات بالأسلحة والمعداتِ الحديثة وتعديلُ جدولِ بناء المعسكرات والمنشآت التابعة للجيش.
وكل ذلك من دون الانجرارِ إلى سباق التسلح مع تحديد عام ألفين وعشرين لإعادة تحديث الجيش بالكامل.
رئيسُ هيئة الأركان العامة للقوات المسلحة الجنرال /فاليري غيراسي-موف/ أكدَّ أيضا أن قواتِ الردع النووية هي أولوية قصوى لدى موسكو كما أنه سيتم هذا العام وضعُ خمسين صاروخا نوويا في الخدمة
وقال إن روسيا تعتزمُ إدخالَ أسلحة تحييدِ الدرع الصاروخي الأمريكي وتم رصد نحو عشرينَ تريليون روبل لاستكمال هذه المهمة.
وفي الوقت الذي تؤكد فيه روسيا أن عقيدتَها العسكرية دفاعيةٌ في الأساس، يواصلُ الإعلامُ الغربي تصويرَ الأمرِ ...
وكأن القادةَ في موسكو يستعدون لحربٍ عالمية ثالثة.. رغم أن من يتوسع على الخريطةِ الجغرافية هو حلفُ شمال الأطلسي ومن ورائه المنظومةُ العسكرية الأمريكية ومشاريعُ الهيمنة.